Метод квантової діагоналізації на основі вибірки, або скорочено SQD, — це квантово-класичний гібридний алгоритм, як Kryov
квантова діагоналізація KQD, як VQE та багато інших. Використовуючи такі гібридні
алгоритми, корисно подумати про те, де кожен алгоритм використовує квантові та класичні обчислення. Згадай, що VQE створює стани на квантовому
circuit за допомогою класично оптимізованих параметрів. У цьому випадку сам стан знаходиться на квантовому комп'ютері. Хоча
отримання цільового стану — це процес, що поєднує як класичні, так і квантові обчислення.
Очікуване значення оператора обчислюється за допомогою квантових вимірювань.
Але також необхідне деяке класичне об'єднання доданків.
На відміну від цього, SQD використовує квантовий комп'ютер для генерації корисного підпростору, на який можна спроектувати гамільтоніан або інший оператор.
Після цього гамільтоніан діагоналізується повністю класично для знаходження цільового стану. Припустимо, є
задача, що цікавить науку або промисловість, яку можна сформулювати як задачу пошуку власних значень на матриці з n рядків і
n стовпців. Припустимо далі, що n достатньо велике, щоб точна класична діагоналізація була неможливою. Було б
явно вигідно зменшити розмірність нашої матриці, зберігаючи всі суттєві характеристики основного стану. Справді, це і є
метою багатьох наближених підходів до пошуку власних значень, включаючи класичні методи Крилова. Припустимо, що ми знаємо достатньо про нашу задачу, щоб зробити
достатньо хорошу здогадку про форму основного стану, але недостатньо, щоб розв'язати задачу напряму. У такому
випадку ми могли б зробити багато вимірювань нашого непоганого наближення до цільового основного стану. Результати цих
вимірювань дають нам підпростір обчислювальних базисних станів, що містять усі суттєві компоненти нашого
основного стану. Проекція на цей підпростір дала б меншу матрицю, яка все ще містить суттєві ступені
свободи. Робочий процес для цього виглядає так. Починаєш з вибору хорошого
анзацу. Точніше, вибираєш анзац, чий носій збігається з носієм цільового стану. Ми обговоримо, що саме
це означає. Далі вимірюєш стан у обчислювальному базисі, як це робиться з примітивом sampler.
Потім використовуєш результати вибірки для визначення підпростору, що містить основний стан.
Потім проектуєш свою матрицю на цей підпростір. Нарешті, класично діагоналізуєш меншу проектовану матрицю.
Розберімо кожен з цих кроків, приділяючи особливу увагу визначенню підпростору.
У всьому квантовому обчисленні вибір хорошого анзацу завжди є критичним. У випадку SQD твій вибір анзацу
визначатиме, які обчислювальні базисні стани можуть бути виміряні під час вибірки.
Справжній основний стан може бути виражений як суперпозиція деякої підмножини обчислювальних базисних станів. Ця підмножина
називається носієм основного стану. Щоб отримати хорошу оцінку основного стану та його енергії, твій анзац
повинен мати ненульову проекцію на обчислювальні базисні стани в носії основного стану.
Ця діаграма представляє простір, натягнутий усіма можливими станами на кількості qubit, що використовуються. Ми хочемо
анзац, носій якого містить носій справжнього основного стану.
Розглянь дуже маленький приклад системи з основним станом s ground = 8 *
стан 1 0 0 плюс 6 * стан 001.
Його носій складається з двох векторів 1 0 0 та 0 1. Скажімо, анзац має форму SNZOT 1 = A разів
стан 1 0 0 плюс B * стан 0 1 0 плюс C * стан 001. Так що його
носій — це множина з трьох векторів 1 0 0, 1 0 і 0 0 1, надмножина
носія основного стану. Це хороший анзац.
Тепер уяви, що замість цього ми вибрали анзац виду szots 2 = a *
стан 1 1 0 плюс b * стан 011.
Його носій складається з двох векторів 11 1 0 та 011, які не перетинаються з носієм основного
стану. Це поганий анзац.
Зауваж, що нам не обов'язково потрібно, щоб анзац був хорошим наближенням основного стану. Анзац може
мати значно більший носій або коефіцієнти можуть дуже відрізнятися в анзаці та справжньому основному стані, і все одно добре працювати.
На цьому етапі ми використали добре обґрунтований анзац, щоб квантовий комп'ютер прийняв стан, схожий на наш цільовий
стан. Тут показано унітарно зв'язаний кластерний джастроу, або UCJ анзац, який дуже корисний у квантовій хімії.
Тепер ми хочемо виміряти стан системи, отримуючи бітові рядки, що описують стан кожного
qubit після колапсу. Згадай, що оцінка гамільтоніана, як у VQE, потребує багатьох квантових вимірювань. Це частково для
зменшення невизначеності, а частково через кількість груп комутуючих операторів Паулі, що складають гамільтоніан.
У методах вибірки тобі все ще потрібно багато вимірювань, але причини інші. Тепер нам потрібно багато вимірювань, щоб ефективно вибирати
багато обчислювальних базисних станів, задіяних у сильно заплутаних квантових станах. У SQD вибрані бітові рядки відповідають
конфігураціям модельованої системи. Якщо система, що вивчається, підпорядковується абсолютним обмеженням, таким як
закони збереження у фізиці або хімії, то більшість виміряних станів будуть дійсними. Але деякі вибрані
бітові рядки відповідають недійсним або нефізичним конфігураціям через шум і помилки. Процес, що називається
відновленням конфігурацій, має на меті уточнити ці зашумлені вибірки до набору більш точних конфігурацій.
Цей процес передбачає генерацію нових конфігурацій шляхом імовірнісного перевертання окремих бітів на основі
усереднених заповненостей орбіталей і відомих чисел частинок.
Уточнені конфігурації потім використовуються для охоплення підпросторів при проекції гамільтоніана та діагоналізації,
ітеративно покращуючи точність представлення квантового стану.
Розглянемо тривіально малий приклад відновлення конфігурацій, щоб зрозуміти його сенс. Припустимо, ми вимірюємо
квантову систему з чотирма qubit, що представляють чотири молекулярні орбіталі, і отримуємо такі бітові рядки від
квантового процесора. Кожен бітовий рядок представляє заповненість орбіталі. Один для
зайнятої, нуль для незайнятої. Qiskit використовує нотацію, в якій найменш значущий qubit знаходиться крайньому праворуч.
WEBVTT
Наприклад, 1 0 1 0 вказує на те, що орбіталі 1 і три зайняті. Ці
вимірювання вибрані лише з педагогічних міркувань. Отримані заповненості можуть не відповідати фізичній системі. У фізичному контексті часто
буває так, що система має відоме загальне число частинок. Також можуть бути інші закони збереження, які
можна використати для визначення фізичності виміряного стану. Щоб бути конкретними, припустімо, що наша система
відомо має загальне число частинок n = 2. Це говорить нам про загальне число одиниць, які мають з'явитися в нашому
позначенні стану, що називається обмеженням ваги Геммінга.
Однак деякі виміряні конфігурації порушують це обмеження. Стан 1 0 1 0 є фізично дійсним. Але стан 1 1
1 0 має забагато частинок, а стан із самих нулів — замало. Нуль
насправді. Ці порушення можуть бути зумовлені шумом у системі або помилками вимірювання. Нам потрібен спосіб повернутися
до конфігурацій, які мають фізичний сенс, хоча б наближено.
Це називається відновленням конфігурацій.
Щоб виправити наші зашумлені вибірки, ми імовірнісно перевертаємо біти в недійсних конфігураціях на основі середньої
заповненості орбіталей, усередненої по дійсних конфігураціях.
Заповненості орбіталей — це очікувані значення оператора числа, що діє на кожну орбіталь. Це оцінюється і
уточнюється самоузгоджено за допомогою станів, отриманих від SQD. Розглянемо, наприклад, орбіталь 2. У двох із
чотирьох дійсних конфігурацій орбіталь 2 була зайнята. Це дає нам очікувану заповненість 0.5.
Робимо те саме для інших трьох орбіталей. Тепер повертаємось до недійсної конфігурації 1 1 0. Ми можемо перевернути один із
бітів з 1 на нуль, щоб отримати дійсну конфігурацію. Але який саме слід перевернути? Один із способів вирішити це —
через відхилення заповненості кожної орбіталі від середніх значень, які ми щойно обчислили.
Тут бачимо, що найбільша різниця у заповненості орбіталі один. Тому можна очікувати, що біт один слід
перевернути з одиниці на нуль. Звичайно, орбіталь 2 теж недалеко. І завжди можливо, хоч і малоймовірно, що
цей виміряний стан є результатом кількох помилок в одному стані.
Вибирати лише найбільше відхилення від середнього для всіх недійсних станів — не оптимально. Натомість біти перевертаються
імовірнісно, де ймовірність є функцією показаних тут різниць. Припустімо, що в цьому
випадку ми справді змінюємо біт, що найбільше відрізняється від середньої заповненості. Тобто 1 1 0 стає 1 1 0 0. Ми зробимо те саме
для іншого недійсного варіанту. Скажімо, у цьому випадку ми перевертаємо біти один і три.
Після цього процесу корекції ми маємо новий набір конфігурацій, який може виглядати так.
Використовуючи цей уточнений набір, ми можемо оновити середню заповненість орбіталей для покращення точності. У нашому випадку нові
заповненості такі.
Цей ітеративний процес відновлення забезпечує фільтрацію зашумлених вимірювань у фізично значущі
конфігурації, покращуючи точність наближень власних станів у SQD. Додаток Qiskit SQD має деякі інструменти, які
стануть у пригоді в цьому процесі. Якщо ми добре вибрали вибірку станів у носії справжнього основного стану
системи, то маємо змогу розглядати лише ті частини гамільтоніана, що діють на цей підпростір,
і все одно отримати хороший основний стан і енергію. У нашому тривіально малому прикладі з 4 qubit спочатку є 2 або 16
можливих станів системи. Використовуючи комбінацію вибірки та відновлення конфігурацій, ми зводимо це
до трьох станів у нашому підпросторі інтересу. Три стани, які, як ми сподіваємось, складають носій справжнього основного стану.
Тепер ми проектуємо повний гамільтоніан на цей підпростір. Тобто ми складаємо матрицю M зі стовпця векторів нашого
відновленого вибіркового підпростору та аналогічну M dagger із рядків і множимо M dagger HM
наочно. Це означає взяття елементів матриці в рядках і стовпцях, що відповідають станам нашого
відновленого вибіркового підпростору. Виділені рядки та стовпці — ті, що відповідають нашому підпростору. А
темніші виділені клітинки, де вони перетинаються, — елементи, які ми зберігаємо для нашої нової проектованої матриці.
Тепер, коли ми виділили підпростір інтересу, ми можемо діагоналізувати цю матрицю на класичному комп'ютері
за допомогою стандартного розв'язувача. Якщо справжній основний стан повністю складається зі станів нашого підпростору, ця
діагоналізація має дати правильний основний стан і енергію основного стану. Якщо ми маємо лише більшу частину носія основного стану,
ми можемо наблизитися. Отримавши основний стан для цього проектованого гамільтоніана, ми маємо дуже
корисний стан, з якого можна обчислити середню заповненість кожної орбіталі.
Раніше наші заповненості обчислювалися зі станів, вибраних за допомогою анзацу, який, як ми сподівалися, допоможе нам
наблизитися до основного стану. Але не було гарантії, що середня заповненість кожної орбіталі з цієї вибірки відповідала заповненості
в стані з найнижчою енергією. Давай відступимо назад. У нас була вибірка обчислювальних станів. Ми використовували відновлення конфігурацій,
щоб виправити ті, що були фізично недійсними. Потім ми обчислили середню заповненість орбіталей, використовуючи всі з них. Але
основний стан може включати лише деякі з них. Основний стан цього проектованого гамільтоніана може бути не справжнім основним
станом нашої початкової системи, але це стан з найнижчою енергією, що може бути створений за допомогою будь-якої суперпозиції
відновлених станів нашого підпростору. Заповненість орбіталей цього стану дасть енергію, меншу або рівну
енергії заповненості, отриманої з відновленого простору. Тому ця заповненість є кращою оцінкою нашої
заповненості основного стану. Ми можемо повторити процес відновлення конфігурацій, використовуючи цю нову заповненість, і можемо ітерувати
до досягнення критеріїв збіжності. Квантова діагоналізація на основі вибірки є швидкою порівняно з
іншими алгоритмами ближнього часу, як VQE. Вона більш масштабована і стійка до шуму та помилок вибірки. Але вона
все ще вимагає, щоб ми підготували хороший анзац із великою проекцією на носій справжнього основного стану нашої системи. Якщо зовсім нічого не відомо
про наш справжній основний стан, SQD може потребувати використання разом з іншими методами, щоб спочатку дізнатися про
основний стан і ітеративно наближатися до нього.
SQD відіграє критичну роль у новому наборі класично-квантових гібридних алгоритмів і є одним із
найбільших рушіїв до корисних квантових обчислень.